feeding time is twice a day at Budds of
Idul bird sanctuary the faster Gomez
select the CLO breasted macaw don't
waste any time living free in nature is
an experience many of these birds aren't
used to Isabel Wenzel has worked here
for more than 15 years and knows pretty
much everybody takes on new challenges
all the bigger birds so he's forever in
the wars and I think if we put his foot
up as a protection sir thank you biting
his toes this huge netted aviary covers
23,000 square meters and is up to 50
meters in height there are more than
3,000 birds here including a group of
red ibises from a private Zoo both come
here need to learn to be Birds so they
need to learn to fly they need to learn
to eat the right food those type of
things and of course we have to also see
that they interact well with each other
that they can interact with the people
that come here because they need to be
safe Shannon whom is responsible for the
integration of their camels she knows
only too well what many of her feathered
friends have been through some have
ripped off their feathers Bodom and ears
in small cages exact a heavy price and
leads to a range of behavioral problems
he was abandoned previous owners these
owners were moving away and the landlord
went to go and check on the house to
make sure everything is still fine and
she found him he immediately phoned us
and asked us what to do and we said we
will take him in and we will eventually
release him outside
but first the rainbow lorikeets will
spend a few weeks here before being
released into the main over
it has to be given a clean bill of
health and learn to be independent
mostly they're more than physically
totally damaged they're very dependent
on humans our process that we try and
get is trying to get them dehumanized
which means we're trying to get them
independent of humans where they can
survive on their own
the sanctuary is financed by the money
visitors been here but they may not turn
the bags because they should again live
as wild animals even in the aviary they
will be able to survive in the wild
around half of their 220 species here
are from Africa the rest from other
parts of the world watched and then sold
every year millions of birds fall
victims to the global trade in wild
animals the pit right in South Africa is
a huge pit it's a huge industry if you
just think of a single one like African
Grey South Africa exports something like
90 thousand big parrots other countries
and it sparked a lot of those one still
originated from the world but Sweden was
gonna bake spit plays a big role and
actually teaching people about don't get
a pet parrot
sadly Mads of Eden is offered many more
bad than it can taking often by people
who can't or don't want to take care of
their pets anymore here they can live
out their lives in relative freedom a
better fit than that of many other birds
held in captivity